Finance year Jeffrey Epstein died before
going to trial to face sex trafficking
charges newly released court documents
detail his extensive Social Circle but
deal with old allegations the people
named so far in the documents include
alleged victims employees and Witnesses
all from a civil lawsuit settled with
Epstein's longtime companion galain
Maxwell herself convicted of sex
trafficking the documents reference many
high-profile people who've acknowledged
visiting Epstein like former presidents
Bill Clinton and Donald Trump Britain's
prince Andrew and former Israeli Prime
Minister ahud Barack but they have
denied any wrongdoing or knowledge of
his criminal activities in a television
interview a lawyer for galain Maxwell
had nothing to say about the release of
the documents but said of the overall
crime quote it's all about men abusing
women for a long period of time and it's
only one person in jail a woman it is
not a Jeffrey Epstein client L to the
way that it's being portrayed by many
people including on social media Kadija
Safar is an investigative reporter who's
exposed how Epstein used his connections
often without their knowledge to recruit
young women even after a 2008 conviction
many of the people who were hobnobbing
with him said they didn't know about his
behavior I think what's often missed in
the story is how these VIP connections
were used to further his sex trafficking
especially after 2008 because he never
stopped abusing women and what he did
was he would dangle money
immigration um help and job
opportunities Epstein's suicide may have
stopped his trial from going forward but
it didn't stop his victims from seeking
financial compensation in a lawsuit
against his bank that case was settled
last
November the United States largest bank
JP Morgan Chase paid
$290 million to roughly 200 of of
Epstein's victims the women accused the
bank in a lawsuit of ignoring warning
signs in his
behavior the released documents show the
links to which Epstein and Maxwell went
to exploit young women for sex but are
not expected to lead to any new charges
against his associates Kristen salumi Al
jazer New
York make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer